hey everybody it's mike from overflows
and today i want to talk about um the
delta footprint chart now
most of you are already familiar with
what a footprint chart is when it comes
to trading order flow but there's
actually several different types of
footprint charts available that you as a
trader can use there's the most common
one which is the bid ask
footprint chart
which is
the one that shows the volume traded on
the bid and the volume traded on the
offer now there's also a
delta footprint chart which shows you
delta at price so say at the price of
44.50
when it was bid there it traded 20
contracts but when it was offered at
44.50 it traded five so that would mean
there's a delta difference of 15 on the
buy side so it would show up as minus 15
because there was uh
20 aggressive sellers versus five
aggressive buyers now there's also a
volume footprint chart
which just shows you the total volume
at price
both the buy and the cell added together
and there's also a diagonal delta
footprint chart now what i'm going to
talk about today is the delta footprint
chart so let's uh let's get our chart up
here real quick
and
okay so this is your normal
volume footprint chart which sorry not
volume footprint chart but rather the
bid ask footprint chart and you can see
the volume that's traded on the bid the
volume that's traded on the offer so you
could
make your decisions based off what
you're seeing in the two-way auction
right so you can see eight lots traded
against zero five against zero two
against 2 12 against 5
10 against 7 3 against 10
okay so that's the normal uh bid ask
footprint chart and most software
i'm using my software the order flows
trader software um should give you the
options right if your software doesn't
give you the option to make it change um
usually like my software is under the
latter content so you can see there's
delta there's volume there's diagonal
delta i'll just show you volume really
quick it's basically it's just the
volume when you take the volume that
traded on the bid the volume trade on
the offer it's going to give you that
number so you can see at this price of
1972 30 uh one lot at 72 28 lots at 72
7 at 72 even 7 and so on it's just the
volume and so it's going to put it on
one side it has to put it on one side of
the footprint so you're going to put it
on the left or the right
um
you know i mean in my software i have
the candle in the middle so it's not
going to put it right down the middle
over overlapping so it's just the volume
that trades at price
now there's also the diagonal delta so
there's the delta and there's the
diagonal delta right remember markets
trade in a two-way auction and if you
want to see what the diagonal delta is
you just change it to diagonal delta now
i don't advocate switching
you know charts midway through trading
it's a great thing to look at after the
market's closed and if it's something
that you want to use going forward set
your charts up that way so each day you
have them you know already open so you
don't have to keep flipping through
chart books etc you know and open up a
new chart changing it you just have to
be ready to go okay so diagonal delta is
showing what's in the two-way auction
the delta now
the
delta the plain delta footprint chart is
what i refer to as the horizontal delta
and that's what i'm going to be talking
about today so let's um
pull it up here really quick
and
okay so it's telling me at this price of
19 right here in the middle 1971 70
there was three lots more traded on the
bid when it was uh 71 70 bid versus when
it was
71.70 offered okay at the price of 7180
there's no volume in there so it's
telling me um
you know it was equal you know it could
be zero could you know it could be zero
traded at both sides it could be one it
could be five you know one and one or
five and five but
there's nothing in um
no one side is in control here you can
see um five right when it was 1971 90
bid there was
five lots more traded than when it was
1971 90 offered right so you're just
taking the horizontal
difference in the volume as opposed to
the bid offer volume and where does this
come in handy is you're going to be able
to see things
that normally you probably wouldn't have
noticed and you know i i made a video
recently discussing heavier than normal
volume
and the same thing applies to delta
right because remember
delta is the net difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
in a bar
okay so if you have
um again above average
normal volume trading
but this time you now you know
you know it just sticks out like a sore
thumb that you know it's going to give
you potentially better trading
opportunities and you know gold is a
great market it follows order flow
nicely
and you know it's not a market like the
e-mini s ps that trades tons and tons of
volume but you know what i'll talk about
yesterday there was a great example if
you are using order flow especially if
you you look at a a delta footprint
chart you can sometimes see things that
you might
otherwise
uh overlook
okay so
uh let me just find it was uh yesterday
was what they say is the 12 so yesterday
was the 11th
and
you can see here right the volumes are
you know
now these are not volumes per se these
are delta volumes so it's not one lot
traded here one lot traded here four and
eight it's the difference
right the difference at a price level
between what traded on the bid and what
traded on the offer so
if you see one it doesn't mean it's just
one lot traded it's a difference of one
lot traded
okay so i know for some people it might
be a little bit confusing at first till
you sort of wrap your head around it but
once you do that then you know it just
becomes a lot easier to understand
okay so here so this is yesterday in the
gold right remember
it was a lot of interesting talk going
on in the gold markets these days with
uh everything going on in russia so this
market you know it was basically trading
around
you know taking anywhere from in here
you know around the
1867 ish area then it starts to sell off
it starts dropping off quite
dramatically you could see the the price
dropping but when you're looking at the
delta footprint
right you see start you're starting to
see some big volumes on the way down
on the offer side
now it's not uncommon to see
big volumes on the bid side on the way
down you know because people are they're
trying to buy the dip right that's all
everyone talks about you know anyone
that's in crypto it's always
by the dip um dollar cost averaging down
you know i was watching
um
you know there's this guy talking about
bitcoin recently i mean where are we now
we're like around 39
40 000 just above just below 40 000. and
he's like i'm just dollar cost averaging
i'm going to be doing this for the rest
of my life
basically he said and you know it's
interesting because
on a dropping market that's why it's not
uncommon to see big volumes or bigger
than normal volumes on the bid side but
when you start seeing them on the offer
side as the market is dropping
right that's telling you sellers are
coming in
they got supply they're putting it out
there on the market it's helping drive
the price lower right so you see this 92
right you don't see any size
really you know here's like a 30
here's a 48 you know here's a 118. this
is on the offer side of an up bar okay
but when you're seeing it on the offer
side of a down bar
realize what's happening markets
dropping sellers are coming in
they're they're dumping it because they
think the price is going lower when you
see it on the offer side and green
candles on the way up
you know oftentimes there's just people
taking profits right that's where you
expect to see it but when you start
seeing it on the offer side as the
market's dropping it's a sign that hey
you know what
it's time to turn you know from the
magnificent seven the movie time to turn
mother's picture to the wall and get out
you know so here's this market it drops
right from you know the 66 area
down into
59 and a half and you see a really big
size here
209 again this is delta right so it's
it's not the actual volume it's the
deltas the difference between the volume
that was traded on the bid when it was
bid there and the volume traded on the
offer when it was offered there so
what's happening sellers are coming in
they're helping to drive the market down
it's not just
markets drop because
sellers are hitting the bid yes i mean
that's what causes the markets to start
moving lower sellers hitting the bid but
what stops the market from retracing
back up is the big offers so you saw it
there right the
92 then you see the next one 209. market
drops down does come back up a little
bit but notice as it comes back up it
comes back up through the this price
area what are you seeing
what are you seeing here right you're
seeing the delta
mostly on the offer side so even though
the market is bounced up a little bit
you still have people offering it out
right people say well mike you know
aggressive buyers are buying it here
right because it's trading on the offer
side
okay yeah people are buying it in
anticipation that this is the bounce
that this move is over but what you have
is you have supply in the market
people are offering it out basically i
don't want to use the term absorption
because i that term gets distorted a lot
nowadays in in order flow but what
you're seeing is
you know the sellers coming in here with
supply and they don't always have to
show you know it's always not going to
trade 200 they could probably have 50 at
a level you know 50 50 50 25 or whatever
different levels spread out it's not
just always going to show everything at
once
and you can see the market sold off
um basically from that 50
you know this is 59 and a half up here
you know all the way down into the mid
50s it's another five dollar move down
okay so that's what it looks like on a
move down on a move up
let's take a look at
10 years okay
excuse me
i like 10 years on a four-range chart
not a minute-based chart
minute based charts on 10 years um
is uh is it pretty similar to watching
paint dry
okay so
uh let's go back i mean today we had
obviously we had the um inflation
numbers come out but let's take a look
at yesterday okay good example yesterday
oh whoops where are we here okay so
you have this nice move down right it's
a nice move down 119. uh 28 here all the
way down to one 1920.
obviously
some numbers come out but you've seen
the big bids coming in here
26 92.
you don't see that sort of size coming
in here
on the offer side or anything even on
the mid side this is what 2508
but now that we hit the low we start
coming back in we have buyers that are
coming into this market 26.92
the market gets bit up some more
another 1800 on the bid side here right
and the market keeps going up
right 10 years is obviously a slower
moving market than
um
gold or e-minis or nasdaq
and the volumes are different okay but
once you understand what decent size
volume is in the market
it should be very easy to see
and
you know let's pull up uh let's pull up
e minis then
uh yeah i'll go to a i'll go to a one
minute chart
again you know today the markets have
been selling off you know it is weird
you know the the white house came out
yesterday and started talking about
inflation and then the inflation number
came out you know market started selling
off yesterday
then the markets the number came out the
markets rallied today i guess people are
expecting a much worse number of the
white house is talking about it the day
before um i just thought it was very
interesting that the white house all of
a sudden came out and started talking
about it yesterday
right ahead in front of a big number um
because you know a lot of people are
scratching their heads when the number
came out today like why is this market
rallying we should be selling off a
little now we're now we're selling off
but uh just really quick let's take a
look how it looks you know on on a
rising market i think um last week you
know we were sort of rallying
um
what time was it
it was around
nine
yeah here right we started rallying up
here okay
just before 10 o'clock this is chicago
time right mark it's just more or less
going sideways in here you know we're
training around you know i don't know
average is around 40 45 86 and then boom
right you got the aggressive buying
coming in here nice and strong
okay he's seen buying imbalances here
stack buying and balance but look at
that size okay 231 okay that's probably
to me that would be sort of on the low
end of
a heavy delta number but look at that
335 so what do you have going on in this
bar right as we're sort of breaking out
of this 4488 area right the swing high
here was like what 44 89 and three
quarters now we start breaking out above
44.90
got the aggressive buying going on here
you can see the buying and balances boom
a big bid boom a big bid now you have
support coming into the market it's
holding up that market right
more aggressive buying boom another big
bid coming in here all right well just
lifting all the offers
right up here right you don't see any uh
volume on the bid side here then you see
255 so they lift all the offers turns a
bid turns a bit up here there's another
579 there's another 249 there's another
238 so you're seeing big bids coming
into the market how do i know these are
big bids without looking at a bid ask
footprint chart well i know it's big
bids because it's the delta at the price
so it's telling me when this market was
44.96
there was 255 lots more traded than when
it was offered at 44.96 remember this is
horizontal delta
okay so at this price
there's or sorry that this price is 96
and a quarter not 96 it's telling me
that there was more interest
in buying it
when the market was going up than there
was in people selling out up here okay
but really what you're looking at is
support coming into the market right and
obviously you know
if you're getting in after this bar here
or even after this bar you mean you're
getting in around you know the 98 99
area definitely below 4 500 and it just
shot straight up to you know the 12.
okay so
you know understand that there's more
than just the bid ask footprint chart i
know some people that's all they look at
is a delta footprint chart they don't
use the bid ask footprint chart
they just focus on the delta footprint
chart and there are things to look for
you know i i have
a special course on trading the delta
footprint chart um but
really what i want you to start to to do
is is look at other ways of using the
order flow rather than just you know a
bid-ask footprint chart a delta
footprint chart gives you great
information
so
if you enjoyed this video be sure to hit
the like button right and that's
important you know i like to get your
feedback that you enjoyed the video and
if you want to see more like this be
sure to click the subscribe button so
when i post them up again i'm trying to
be a little bit more proactive this year
sort of my new year's resolution coming
in april that i'm going to try and get
more videos out there for everyone to
learn more about order flow so thanks
everyone bye bye